وقد اعلن الرئيس الاوكراني فيما ورد قبل
قليل عن مقتل 47 شخصا على الاقل في قصف
روسي استهدف منطقه خاركيف شرقي البلاد
وينضم الينا من زبروجيا مراسل الجزيره
الياس كرام الياس ما التفاصيل حول هذا
الهجوم بالفعل والعدد عدد الضحايا يبدو
انه ارتفع في الدقائق الاخيره الى 49 شخصا
وهناك على الاقل سته جرحى من بين ال
المصابين في هذا القصف الصاروخي الروسي
على بلده جروزا هذه البلده الواقعه الى
القرب من كوبيانسك في مقاطعه خاركيف القصف
بحسب الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
مقاطعه خاركيف طال مقها ومحلا تجاريا يبدو
انه كان مليئا ب السكان سكان هذه القريه
قريه جروزا وهو ما اوقع هذا العدد الكبير
من الق القتلى والجرحى نحن نتحدث بحسب اخر
تحديث وصلنا الان من الاداره العسكريه في
اقليم خاركيف الى 49 قتيلا وسته جرحى من
بينهم طفل ويبدو ان هنالك ايضا ما زال
ضحايا تحت الانقاد في هذا المحل التجاري
وال المقهى الذي استهدف بالقصف الاداره
العسكريه لم تشر حتى الان عن طبيعه ال
القصف الذي استهدف هذا المكان ان كان قصفا
مدفعيا او بصواريخ جراد او ان كانت غاره
جويه استهدفت هذه القريه لكن نحن نتحدث عن
منطقه تشهد في الاسابيع الاخيره تبادلا
عنيفا لاطلاق قذائف الجراد والقذائف
الصاروخيه بين الجيشين الاوكراني والروسي
الذي يحاول ان يعيد السيطره على منطقه
كوبيانسك الذي كان الجيش الاوكراني قد نجح
في تحريرها قبل عام تقريبا ونجح بتحرير
مساحه كبيره من مقاطعه خاركيف تقدر بنحو
8500 م مربع ونجح في هذا التحرير الكبير
الى تحرير نحو 350 بلده وقريه اوكرانيه في
هذا المحور و جروزا هي واحده من هذه
البلدات التي تمكن الجيش الاوكراني من
تحريرها في هذا الهجوم المعاكس قبل نحو
عام الان هذه البلده تتعرض كما اشرنا الى
هذا القصف الذي لم تتضح معالمه بعد وواضح
بان ال عدد الضحايا سواء قتلى او جرحى هو
مرشح للارتفاع ذلك ان القصف كما يبدو
استهدف محلا تجاريا في ساعه الذروه هذه
الساعه التي يتوجه فيها الاوكرانيين عاده
الى المحال التجاريه للتبضع ويبدو ان
المكان كان
مليئا بالسكان بسكان هذه الق وهو ما يفسر
هذا العدد الكبير من الضحايا في هذا القصف
شكرا جزيلا لك الياس كرام من زبرو وما كنا
نشاهده قبل قليل ومازال على شاشتنا الان
هي صور لذا القصف الروسي الذي يقول الرئيس
الاوكراني وتقول السلطات الاوكرانيه على
بلده جروزه انه اوقع
قتيلا